hola bienvenidos otra vez digamos que yo
tengo tres manzanas luego luego yo te
regalo otras siete manzanas y entonces
me pregunta para ti es la cual tal vez
sea una pregunta bastante obvia es
cuantas manzanas tengo ahora cuantas
manzanas tengo ahora y piensa en esto
por un segundo aunque tal vez sea un
poco obvio es es algo muy básico pero
bueno tienes tres manzanas luego te doy
otras siete manzanas y tres más siete
ahora tienes diez manzanas pero digamos
que yo quiero hacer lo mismo solo que
bueno soy muy floja para escribir la
palabra manzanas así que simplemente voy
a escribir la letra a como representando
manzanas inició con cuatro manzanas
tengo primero cuatro as
y a esto le agrego otras dos as
cuántas as tengo ahora cuántas as tengo
ahora veamos esto piensa en esto por un
segundo observarlo bien te daré unos
segundos para que pienses en tu
respuesta y tal vez tal vez para ti sea
un tanto obvio un sentido como un
trivial tal vez si tienes cuatro as sea
lo que sea que éstas representan tienes
cuatro y le agregas otras dos entonces
tendrás seis
finalmente asumimos que las representan
manzanas pero pero en sí pueden ser
cualquier cosa pueden representar
cualquier cosa tienes cuatro as lo que
tú quieras que representen las as tienes
cuatro y le sumas otras dos
finalmente tendrás 6 as ahora puedes
pensar en estas en estas cuatro hojas
como esto es lo mismo que a más a más a
más
y a eso yo le agrego otras dos hace
entonces más a más
y bueno cuántas tengo finalmente son son
1 2 3 4 5 6 6 finalmente ahora pensemos
en esto de una manera un tanto más un
tanto más abstracta digamos que yo tengo
yo tengo 5 x x puede representar
cualquier cosa cualquier número en
cualquier cosa perros gatos manzanas
elefantes lo que tú quieras tengo 5 x 5
veces algún número y le restó 2 x a que
se va a simplificar esto cuántas de
estas x tendré finalmente tengo 5 x 2 x
es igual a qué cosa multiplicando a x
piénsalo bien piénsalo unos segundos 5 x
menos 2 x a cuántas x es igual
veamos si yo tengo 5 veces algo y le
restó 2 de esas cosas me quedarán tres
de ese de ese algo cierto por lo tanto
esto es igual esto es igual a 3 x 5 x
menos 2 x es igual a 13
es lo mismo que x mas x + x mas x + x y
luego le quitamos dos de esas x entonces
esta se va y esta se va y me quedan
finalmente 3 x ahi estan las 3 x bueno
nos vemos pronto